bonjour à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur public sénat revoici et le programme
de votre après midi dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre l'audition par les
sénateurs de la commission du
développement durable de ségolène royal
la ministre de l'écologie au coeur
aujourd'hui d'une polémique pour ses
prises de position sur le diesel ou
encore l'éco taxe souvent à
contre-courant de la ligne
gouvernementale
puis son audition sera suivie par celle
de pierre rené lemas ancien secrétaire
général de l'elysée est candidat à la
direction générale de la caisse des
dépôts et puis je vous retrouve à 19h
pour le 24 heures sénat autre temps fort
de l'actualité du sénat c'est l'examen
en séance publique
en ce moment même d'une proposition de
loi qui vise à réduire l'activité des
moniteurs de ski qui ont atteint l'âge
de la retraite on en parle à 19 heures
en bref la commission mixte paritaire
sur le projet de loi de simplification
du droit a échoué ce matin pour jean
pierre sueur le président ps de la
commission des lois et bien il ne faut
pas recourir aux ordonnances en matière
de droit civil c'est ce que demandait le
gouvernement dans ce texte ainsi que
l'assemblée nationale il y aura donc une
nouvelle lecture par les députés et par
les sénateurs et en cas de désaccord
c'est l'assemblée nationale qui aura le
dernier mot l'ancien garde des sceaux
robert badinter a été auditionné
également au sénat aujourd'hui par la
mission d'information sur le système
prostitutionnel
et je vous propose souci de l'écouté
la prostitution occasionnelle
la prostitution pour une période où est
certaine moment est une des
caractéristiques
du de ce mal moderne
pan des raisons qui sont multiples
insultes période de grandes difficultés
économiques
insuffisance de ressources ou bien
pour certaines ou certains
le goût de pouvoir s'offrir
tel vêtement telles vacances evra bref
des plaisirs dispendieux ou revenir eux
que leur situation ne leur permet pas
d'avoir cela entraîne des phénomènes des
périodes de prostitution occasionnelle
l'état civil des transsexuels en débat
au sénat après la victoire de conchita
bourse à l'eurovision la sénatrice
europe ecologie les verts esther
benbassa a présenté ses propositions
concernant le changement d'identité et
l'état s'il des personnes transsexuelles
écoutez ses explications suivi du
témoignage d'un transsexuel au micro de
jennifer sait mais
c'est une avancée pour les transsexuels
parce qu'actuellement le processus de
transition est terriblement
humiliant c'est une vraie souffrance
parce que actuellement en france en gros
là le changement de prénom et de la
mention de l'identité sexuelle est
aujourd'hui
judiciariser et médicalisée on est en
plus il n'ya pas de loi vous avez
jusqu'à aujourd'hui il n'y a pas eu de
loin ce sont des jurisprudences ces
confrontations au quotidien d'aller
justement prouver son identité pour une
infraction pour aller chercher un colis
pour aller voter tout simplement on doit
toujours essayer des pressions identité
et à chaque fois c'est une obligation
chez rené lemas ancien secrétaire
général de l'elysée a été entendu par le
parlement qui a donné son feu vert à sa
nomination à la tête de la caisse des
dépôts en remplacement de jean-pierre
jouyet elle son audition sera à suivre
sur l'antenne de public sénat à partir
de 18 heures je vous disais ségolène
royal la ministre de l'ecologie vient
d'arriver au sénat en pleine tourmente
sur ses prises de position iconoclastes
elle est entendu par les sénateurs pour
en parler en accueille thème tran huy
bonjour ta main alors je viens de dire
un ségolène royal est en pleine
tourmente en aiguille puisque dans un
entretien à paraître demain dans paris
match dont n'avons pour l'instant que
quelques extraits que quelques bribes la
ministre de l'ecologie critiquerait
ouvertement le ministre des finances
michel sapin sur l'écotaxe et il le
ministre de l'économie arnaud montebourg
sur le dossier alstom par ailleurs elle
dénonce les boules puantes et le mépris
de certains de ses collègues bref
ambiance ambiance au gouvernement tout
un poème qui met à mal la cohésion
gouvernementale
alors après cette sortie programmée un
je le répète puisque c'est à paraître
demain il ya d'abord eu ce midi le
recadrage celui de stéphane le foll le
porte-parole du gouvernement qui assure
que la solidarité la cohésion
gouvernementale
et bien c'est sacré et après le
recadrage le rétropédalage puisqu'à la
sortie du conseil des ministres ségolène
royal tout à l'heure n'a plus de
préférence dans le dossier alsthom on
les écoute
ces offres sont en train de s'améliorer
c'est une bonne chose pour l'emploi en
france mais je n'ai pas de préférence à
ce stade
je note simplement que ce matin de
l'offre de siemens dans cette dynamique
européenne s'est améliorée j'ai pas
donner d'interview en tant que tel voilà
il ya des discussions entre ministres de
discussions franches mais nous sommes
très solidaires les uns des autres on le
voit ta main le logiciel anti coque
n'est pas encore opérationnel et au delà
de la polémique du jour bien ségolène
royal s'est en plus se démarquer sur la
transition énergétique et oui après hier
bien la taxation du diesel aujourd'hui
c'est la fameuse écotaxe qui a du plomb
dans l aile la ministre de l'ecologie
est très sceptique aussi bien sur le
contrat passé avec ecomouv contrat qui
avait été passée par le gouvernement
fillon que sur le principe même de
l'écotaxe là dessus et dale contredit
les conclusions de la mission
d'information de l'assemblée nationale
qui elle se prononce pour un maintien de
l'écotaxe mais remanié merci beaucoup
tam alors sans plus tarder on prend la
direction de la salle médicis ou
l'audition de ségolène royal vient de
débuter à tout à l'heure des économies
d'énergie des énergies renouvelables des
infrastructures de transport propres etc
je pense que c'est une chance formidable
d'avoir ce défi à relever est mon
objectif c'est de créer cent mille
emplois grâce à la transition énergie
écologique et énergétique
c'est un objectif que j'ai fixé à
l'ensemble des services du ministère et
nous allons l'atteindre grâce à la
mobilisation des filières économiques à
la fois des grands groupes dont j'ai
déjà rencontré la plupart des dirigeants
et de tout le tissu des pme et des pmi
et des sous traitants de ces grands
groupes
d'ailleurs vendredi prochain je réunis
les 10 grandes filières des industries
du futur vous savez qu'ils font partie
des trente quatre filières d'avenir avec
mon collègue arnaud montebourg et il y
en a dix qui ont un lien très direct
avec cette mutation écologique cette
mutation énergétique et des fleurons
industriels
sur lesquels 12 pour lesquels nous
devons accélérer le potentiel de
commandes publiques de commandes privées
et de capacités de développement
le deuxième objectif la deuxième méthode
je parle un peu de méthodologie donc là
la préoccupation c'est la croissance
verte la création d'emplois et le
développement économique la deuxième
c'est là mouvement des territoires et on
le sait bien rien ne se fera sans la
mise en mouvement des territoires et
tout se fera avec eux vous savez bien
vous qui sur vos territoires regardez
l'application de ceux de ce nouveau
potentiel de la mutation énergétique de
l'excellence environnementale
et pour avoir été longtemps présidente
de région c'est vrai je découvre à quel
point parfois des impulsions données au
niveau national reste lettre morte parce
que souvent elles mettent du temps à
arriver sur le territoire
et là nous avons la chance d'être là
d'avoir l'échéance devant nous des
nouveaux contrats de plan état région en
particulier donc je souhaite que le
volet mobilité des contrats de plan le
volet biodiversité des contrats de plan
et le volet du haut débit numérique
parce que c'est très lié aussi à la
révolution énergétique soient rapidement
signés même si la totalité des
contraintes plan n'est pas prêt il
faudrait accélérer dans ces trois
domaines pour que les signatures se
fasse et que nous puissions engagé
financièrement les travaux
relatifs à ces priorités des territoires
des régions et des agglomérations
voilà donc le troisième volet et ses
geôliers a peu évoqué tout à l'heure
avec la croissance verte c'est la
mobilisation des filières économiques je
pense que c'est ça c'est très important
parce qu'on se rend compte que il ya un
potentiel considérable
et que nous avons la responsabilité de
saisir cette chance formidable
de pouvoir créer des emplois non
délocalisables
des emplois très qualifiés des nouveaux
métiers liés par exemple à la
performance énergétique des bâtiments on
sait qu'aujourd'hui les filières des
bâtiments est en difficulté et c'est
vrai que si on arrive à déclencher les
filières et les grands chantiers sur la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments sur
les travaux d'isolation va apporter une
bouffée d'oxygène à des milliers des
dizaines de milliers et de petites et
moyennes entreprises et de tout
l'artisanat des métiers du bâtiment sur
le sur le territoire
alors pour pour arriver à cela j'ai
identifié six grands domaines d'action
sur lesquels je sais que d'avancer le
plus vite possible d'accélérer les
choses en les prenant à bras le corps
d'abord c'est le premier c'est la mise
en place d'un nouveau modèle énergétique
avec vous le savez donc la finalisation
du projet de loi sur la transition
énergétique
il y aura peut-être quelques questions
donc je gouvernement veut accélérer les
choses et que les consultations le texte
partent assez rapidement conseil
économique et social et environnemental
ce que vous savez que c'est la procédure
au conseil national de la transition
écologique et puis ensuite bien sûr le
travail dans les commissions qui devrait
pouvoir commencer au mois de juillet
voilà ensuite à l'accélération des
filières d'énergies renouvelables
vous avez vu que plusieurs parcs éoliens
en mer ont été attribuées récemment et
donc l'éolien en mer le solaire la
biomasse et énergies marines il y a là
des filières de développement avec des
entreprises françaises très performante
et donc j'ai l'intention là aussi de
pousser en avant
c'est ces filières économiques et là
aussi si les sénateurs ont des idées sur
ces sujets là par rapport à ce qu'il
voit sur le territoire comme certains
projets qui sont bloqués soit par des
réglementations soit par des recours
interminable on est en train de je suis
en train de voir pourquoi est ce que
dans certains pays me dis certaines
entreprises des énergies renouvelables
les choses sont plus rapides et donc il
ya une compétition industrielle qui se
fait il faut vraiment que la france
adapte ses procédures contentieuses en
particulier pour qu'elles soient
raccourcis sans bien sûr remettre en
cause les droits des requérants verte
pour que cela soit raccourci est
compatible avec des projets économiques
viables le troisième thème dans le
nouveau modèle énergétique ça va être
l'accélération de la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments avec
la problématique du financement je suis
en train de travailler pour qu' il y ait
la mobilisation des fonds souvent qui
existent déjà d'ailleurs qu'on pourrait
sans doute mobiliser plus rapidement
puisque la banque publique
d'investissement avait été désigné comme
banque de la transition écologique de la
transition énergétique
donc elle fait son travail d'ailleurs
vont peut-être trouver des idées pour
accélérer c'est ses interventions et
puis la mobilisation des fonds de la
caisse des dépôts et consignations qui
on vous le savez devait être mobilisée
sur ce sur ce priorité là donc on est en
train de travailler pour trouver une
ingénierie financière
qui permettent d'accélérer tous les
travaux par exemple certaines communes
ne le savent peut-être pas mais pour
avoir eu aussi en tant que président de
région signé un accord de partenariat
avec la caisse des dépôts aujourd'hui
les communes peuvent emprunter 1 million
d'euros sans apport initial un taux de 2
2% sur entre sur une durée de 20 à 40
ans donc pour faire les travaux
d'isolation d'énergie sur les bâtiments
municipaux sur les écoles voire sur les
pour les communautés de communes sur les
bâtiments industriels ou les bâtiments
commerciaux qui sont mises à disposition
des entreprises il ya un potentiel
considérable et donc je souhaite que les
circuits courts se met en place sur la
mobilisation de ses financements pour
qu'au moins dans la commande publique il
puisse y avoir des engagements rapides
des travaux d'isolation d'énergie
dans cette perspective nous sommes en
train de travailler à l'organisation de
la conférence bancaire et financière de
la transition énergétique pour justement
stabiliser les règles et stabiliser les
financements et pour faire en sorte que
ce processus se met en place
voilà ensuite sûrs à la finalisation du
projet de loi réformant le code minier
effectivement le deuxième chantier c'est
la protection et la reconquête de l'eau
de la biodiversité des paysages donc sur
ce thème vous y avait déjà beaucoup
travaillé j'imagine il ya l'examen au
parlement du projet de loi sur la
biodiversité
donc c'est un sujet aussi très important
qui n'est pas sans lien meilleur avec le
projet de loi sur l'énergie puisque
c'est aussi avec des des techniques des
technologies de protection de la planète
qu'on maintient et même qu'on arrive à
reconquérir la biodiversité donc c'est
un domaine passionnant qui passionne qui
passionne les français d'ailleurs avec
un une soif de connaissances sur la
variété des espèces animales végétales
sur quels sont les liens avec avec la
vie humaine et chaque fois qu'une espèce
disparaît c'est la vie humaine qui est
fragilisé et j'étais récemment faire
toute une journée de travail au muséum
d'histoire naturelle rencontrer les
chercheurs et c'était vraiment
passionnant parce qu'ils ont mis en
place la science participative c'est à
dire des activités dans les écoles où
les élèves sont amenés à repérer les
espèces les papillons le déplacement et
c est vraiment on voit plus une passion
souvent il y avait des grands parents
les arrière grands parents qui
apprennent et cinq petits enfants puis
petit à petit cette cette connaissance
du milieu naturel se perd il faut
absolument retransmettre aux jeunes
générations
le sens du respect de la nature la
connaissance de la nature la
connaissance des sciences de la vie et
ça c'était ce sont des chantiers
éducatifs aussi très importants sur
lesquels auquel j'attache beaucoup de
beaucoup de soins
ensuite le troisième thème c'est ce
thème de la santé santé environnement et
prévention des risques donc comme vous
le savez peut-être j'ai fait adopter par
le conseil national par le conseil
national de la transition écologique
l'adoption de la stratégie sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens
donc on avait des engagements sur ce
sujet là je les aient accéléré je suis
allé même sur le terrain pour faire en
sorte que
voilà les prochaines et prochaine
interdiction soit soient adoptées
notamment le bisphénol l'élimination du
bisphénol dans les emballages
alimentaires et dans les tickets de
caisse pourquoi les tickets de caisse
parce que paradoxalement voyez quand les
caissières ou quand les vendeuses
peuvent son enceinte et ne peuvent peut
être vous mise et peuvent plus être
debout on les mettait ok sauf qu'en
manipulant plusieurs dizaines par
centaines hommes dizaines de kilos de
papier au bisphénol eh bien ça provoque
des malformations congénitales et ça
c'est pas acceptable et donc car
heureusement il ya une prise de
conscience il ya des industriels qui ont
déjà anticipé donc je me suis rendu
récemment dans des enseignes de
distribution qui ont déjà éliminé le
bisphénol qui sera interdit au 1er
janvier 2015 même chose pour les
phtalates dans les jouets ce que les
enfants portent à la bouche des jouets
de mon les jouets importés est très
important aussi que les avec elle à la
sécurité sanitaire soient préservés il
est tout problème des parabènes aussi
heureusement là avec une prise de
conscience aussi et donc il y aura de
toute façon une obligation d'étiquetage
et une série de produits interdits pour
lesquels justement je dis aux
industriels mais innover trouver des
produits de substitution et si vous êtes
les premiers à trouver des produits de
substitution
vous avez conquérir le marché mondial
puisque de toute façon ces produits
seront également interdits au niveau
européen et au niveau mondial veille
comment une norme au lieu d'être une
contrainte devient une chance à dire si
la france anticipe les normes elle va
anticiper les savoir faire industriel et
du coup elle va conquérir les marchés
économiques correspondant à ces normes
qui de toute façon vont être imposés
dans le cas du respect de la santé
publique
nous aurons toujours dans le domaine de
la prévention des risques l'approbation
de la stratégie nationale de gestion du
risque inondation ça c'est aussi un
problème difficile parce que coûteuse
j'en sais quelque chose que dans la
région on a eu des problèmes de xynthia
avec des victimes
reconstruire les digues mais il est
évident que
il faut gérer ce problème au niveau non
seulement des du littoral mais aussi des
rivières donc est un travail qui a
commencé sur la gestion du risque
inondation et il va falloir on
al'obligation de toute façon d'arrêter
une stratégie nationale
il ya aussi l'élaboration du plan
déchets à l'horizon 2020 là aussi c'est
l'anticipation du plan déchets ça permet
de créer des activités des emplois au
lieu d'y être contrainte on anticipe et
donc si on anticipe ont réduit aussi les
déchets à la source et si on réduit les
déchets à la source on a aussi des
entreprises plus performantes
parce que moins consommatrice de
matières premières ce qu'on appelle
l'économie circulaire donc vous voyez
mon souci c'est de montrer comment à
chaque fois qu'il ya que la protection
de l'environnement ce n'est pas une
contrainte mais ça peut être utilisé
comme une chance la mort si on va vite
dans la conviction c'est que dans la
transition écologique l'on va vite - ça
coûte cher parce que plus on anticipe et
puis on est les premiers à savoir faire
et comme ce savoir faire maintenant avec
la transparence démocratique à l'échelle
de la planète et de toute façon en
l'engagement de l'organisation des
nations-unies sur les normes mais c'est
des enjeux industriels des conquêtes
industriel qu'il faut faire et nos
laboratoires de recherche nos grandes
entreprises sont quand même très bien
placé pour être les plus jeunes et plus
judicieuse les plus astucieux sur ce
domaine y compris avec des partenariats
européens
nous aurons aussi à préparer la
négociation européenne sur les ogm donc
là vous avez adopté un texte législatif
qui va dans ce sens ce sera aussi
l'occasion aux niveaux au niveau
européen de
d'approfondir la question de de la
grille écologie ou de la façon voilà de
la production plus respectueuse de
l'environnement et plus respectueuse de
la santé des consommateurs là aussi je
dois dire que la profession agricole
évolue énormément et ça c'est très
réconfortant
parce que aussi elle s'est rendu compte
que avec les labels et avec les normes
de produits en diminuant les pesticides
ça devenait un atout et un argument de
vente donc au lieu d'être subi et d'être
vu comme une contrainte c'est ça devient
à une opportunité et à la toupie le
consommateur étant de plus en plus
informés
et bien le fait de faire un effort pour
deux pour diminuer les pesticides donne
un avantage compétitif
supplémentaires
sur les transports donc
mon collègue frédéric cuvillier a la
charge de ce
ce domaine y compris les transports et
la mer donc comme je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure ce qui serait très intéressant
c'est de pouvoir civ demande à toutes
les régions de signer les volets
mobilité des contrats de plan en
partenariat avec les agglomérations
ça serait formidable parce qu'on aurait
de la visibilité sur les besoins
financiers
et donc je vais tous les préfets de
région pour dire voilà avancées sur les
volets mobilité des contrats de plan
parce que comme ça on aura une
cartographie donc c'est quoi le volet
mobilité vous le savez cette fois les
routes les autoroutes le fret
ferroviaire et puis les transports
urbains comme ça on a une visibilité on
regarde après dans la conférence
bancaire de combien on a besoin et
comment est ce que les régions même
peuvent faire la vence des fonds par
rapport aux prêts de la caisse des
dépôts et consignations et comment on
peut mobiliser ses crédits pour engager
les chantiers
il y aura l'examen du projet de loi de
réforme ferroviaire et c'est frédéric
cuvillier qui en a la charge alors
ensuite le dernier thème tous et tous
les emplois nouveaux et la croissance
verte donc c'est un thème c'est un thème
horizontale le dernier temps les rendez
vous internationaux donc sur le sur la
croissance verte donc j'ai dit il ya le
développement des filières d'avenir donc
1 à 10 dans le cadre des trente quatre
filières des 34 plan industriel
vous êtes invités à l'air vous êtes
volontiers faudrait confier si vous
voulez assister à certaines réunions de
travail du ministère normalement vous
recevez l'agenda donc mais je vais
veiller à ce que ça soit fait et par
exemple la jeu vendredi matin toute la
matinée de travail avec les dix filières
industrielles
donc c'est vrai que si certains sur
votre territoire vous avez cessé filière
industrie du futur mais les réunions
sont sont ouvertes est bien évident ou
vous pouvez y participer
ensuite il y aura la mise en oeuvre du
volet transition énergétique des
investissements d'avenir donc là je sais
aussi que des financements sont déjà
mobilisés sur votre territoire donc
l'idée aussi c'est de continuer à les
repérer et à les pousser en avant et à
les accompagner
on a engagé un chantier aussi va qui
était déjà engagée que je souhaite
accélérer c'est la modernisation et la
simplification du droit de
l'environnement je crois qu'on a un
droit de l'environnement et des plus
complexes d'europe et d'autres pays sont
pas moins plus mal protégés que nous
donc il faut vraiment la con et qu'on
fasse un gros travail parce que la
protection de l'environnement ne doit
pas se retourner contre l'emploi n'en
peut mais on peut bien protégé bien
respecté le l'environnement tout en ne
freinant pas l'activité économique
industriel et l'emploi
voilà enfin il y aura les grands rendez
vous européens et internationaux donc il
ya eu une réunion des ministres de
l'énergie du g7 les 5 et 6 mai à rome
auquel j'ai participé avec l'idée de
faire émerger des projets européens
malgré nos modèles énergétiques très
différents évidemment nous nous avons le
nucléaire dans le mix énergétique
d'autres pays ils refusent c'est pas
pour ça qu'on ne doit pas essayer de
monter en commun des projets notamment
sur les énergies renouvelables sur les
économies d'énergie sur la performance
énergétique des bâtiments parce que là
certains pays aussi ont des savoir faire
pour nous on est peut-être en retard sur
certains sujets on était en avance sur
d'autres donc l'idée c'est de tirer
l'ensemble des pays européens vers le
haut pour avoir un mix énergétique qui
respecte les identités énergétique de
chacun tout en contribuant à la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
nous avons bien sûr comme vous le savez
le le conseil des ministres européens du
12 juin le conseil des mineurs de
l'environnement le conseil des ministres
de l'énergie le 13 juin pour préparer
justement le le conseil européen afin
que des décisions soient prises au
niveau des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement pour préfigurer la
conférence de paris climat de 2015 très
difficile cette conférence par et climat
mais c'est en étant très attendu
et moi je suis convaincu qu'avec la
prise de conscience mondiale sur les
perturbations climatiques des drames et
les tragédies que cela provoque à
l'échelle planétaire la montée du niveau
du niveau des mers la disparition de
certains pays insulaire la fragilisation
des côtes sont par exemple les côtes
africaines commencent à se dégrader
considérablement
les migrations de la misère due au
réchauffement de tous les pays de la
zone saharienne avec des déplacements
massifs de population pour accéder à des
pays qui fut le dessèchement climatiques
les conflits futurs liés au contrôle de
l'accès à l'eau potable bref on a même
s'ils sont des échéances que nous ne
verrons pas on a une responsabilité à
l'égard des générations qui viennent
d'agir en toute conscience et pour
accélérer vraiment le la transition
énergétique est vraiment pour réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
ensuite nous aurons les réunions en juin
pour l'assemblée des nations unies pour
l'environnement puisque et des
négociations internationales sur le
climat donc voyez à toute une série
d'échéances internationales qui vont
sans boiter et l'idée c'est quand même
que l'europe soit exemplaire parce que
si l'europe arrive avec un projet même
partielle sur un certain nombre
d'objectifs et pourra peut-être
entraîner d'autres continents et puis si
chaque continent peut mettre sur la
table un certain nombre de projets par
exemple les projets africaine africains
ou sur l'amazone il ya la forêt par
exemple eh bien si chacun peut
s'exprimer aussi sur les préoccupations
et sur les menaces plus spécifiques qui
les touchent on aura du coup une prise
de conscience géographique et multiforme
mais en août rend très cohérente mais
tous les pays insulaires par exemple
tire la sonnette d'alarmé alors ils
tirent la sonnette d'alarmé une fois
dans les réunions internationales
ensuite ils voient les gens chaque art
retourne chez soi et ensuite ils
reviennent et disent mais attention on
est en train de disparaître sous le
niveau de la mer qu'est ce qu'on fait et
c'est donc c'est pour ça que la
conférence par un climat et est une
échéance très importante et qu'elle se
prépare dès maintenant
dans le cadre de la construction du
monde meilleur que nous souhaitons merci
de votre attention
merci madame tous les cas on a pour le
moment on se demande de parole je pense
qu'on va prendre une première série de
cinq ou six
et puis on fera de deux paquets de
demandes de parole aussi
mais
on va essayer de le faire c'est déjà en
piste
le script de service soit essayer de le
faire bien dans les demandes historiques
je parle de la peine devant monsieur le
ministre vous vous aussi monsieur
bourque à
madame la ministre vous avez bien
compris qu'il y en a 12 au moins sinon
13 maintenant et donc essayer d'être
concis s'il vous plaît à la mamie c'est
avec beaucoup d'intérêt qu'on nous avons
écouté votre exposé sur les questions
économiques en faisant en sorte de ne
pas opposer économie environnement mais
au contraire en montrant que c'est un
secteur d'innovation pour le futur
vous avez abordé les questions de l'eau
de la biodiversité de la santé j'ai un
problème en franche comté et je vous ai
écrit madame la ministre sur un des
problèmes qui a trait à la fois au
développement économique à l'eau à la
biodiversité à la santé les trois
rivières que vous connaissez bien c'est
à dire pour toutes celles et ceux qui
ont vu les tableau de courbet
la loue
le doubs la franco-suisse et le
dessoubre sont très malade malade un
point où samedi il y aura une
manifestation très importante
pour sauver nos rivières la directe avec
la préfecture du doubs avec le conseil
régional et le conseil général sont
mobilisés sur ces questions depuis deux
ans on ne voit pas de solution
l'université travaille avec nous et le
cheptel piscicole est en train de
disparaître donc c'est un émoi
considérable en sachant que ce sont des
lieux de pêche
d'europe voire même du monde entier et
qui venez là et là toute l'activité
touristique est mise en sommeil il y a
des choses qui dépendent bien sûr des
collectivités locales et territoriales
mais il ya aussi des choses qui
dépendent de l'état et notamment des
pouvoirs de police de l'état par exemple
l'arrêt immédiat des traitements en
forêt des grumes on a développé la
filière bois c'est une bonne chose mais
traiter les grumes aux abords des
rivières c'est une catastrophe
deuxième chose le classement en zone
vulnérable nitrates de l'air
géographique des aop
nous avons un sol karstique c'est ce qui
fait sa beauté dans lé tableau de
courbet on voit ces ces reculs et qui
sont magnifiques et bien comme c'est un
sol karstique le lisier quand il est mis
à côté de la rivière qui coule
immédiatement dans la rivière auparavant
c'était sur la paille et maintenant il
ya des déversement de lisier qui crée
des conditions mais effroyable pour les
écosystèmes dernière chose on
s'interroge s'il ne faut pas que j'aie
j'apprécie beaucoup votre position
courageuse sur le bisphénol c'est très
difficile économiquement mais c'est une
position d'avenir
est-ce que des des produits comme le
roundup parce qu'aujourd'hui on désherbe
parfois dans l'agriculture intensive au
roundup est ce que dans un bassin
versant où il ya du sol karstique ces
produits là ne devrait pas être
définitivement interdite
c'est là excusez moi excusez moi quand
vous voyez l'étendue des dégâts
continuons à faire de l'intensif et vous
verrez que on aura des écosystèmes et
des écosystèmes qui seront mises en
danger voilà madame la ministre
l'intervention je voulais faire au nom
de tous les élus franc comtois parce que
ce qui se passe est tragique et il
faudra réagir au niveau où les problèmes
se posent merci de votre réponse je 13
monsieur de la commission de
développement durable
merci madame la ministre
j'ai bien apprécié tout à l'heure votre
façon de voir est votre politique qui
consiste plutôt anticiper que à subir ça
ça me plaît ça me convient j'ai quatre
questions à vous poser la première
sur l'écotaxe qui est devenue une éco
redevance
et pour lequel nos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale ont fait un
rapport qui quant à moi je l'ait pas
encore totalement lui j'ai lu que la
synthèse me paraissait assez équilibré
alors
comment conciliez-vous la taxation des
poids lourds vous nous aviez ouvert deux
pistes la dernière fois taxation des
poids lourds étrangers par rapport aux
règles européennes et deuxièmement je
dirais la taxation supplémentaire sur
les autoroutes qui étaient deux pistes
vous en êtes où à ce niveau là et on n'a
ni ou parce que sur cette éco taxe éco
redevance nous sur le terrain nous
attendons parce que ces 800 millions
d'euros donc vous avez dit tout à
l'heure et de là aussi je vous apprécie
beaucoup vous avez dit tout à l'heure
que vous étiez prête à aller très très
vite au moins la moitié de ce caillou
mon collègue monsieur le président beau
donc vous étiez prête à aller très très
vite et donc dans ce domaine le
troisième appel à projets le cepeo
mobilité et notamment les
infrastructures ferroviaires et lafitte
pour l'instant nous sommes dans le plus
complet
ignorance donc où en sommes-nous ensuite
sur le mécano industriel alstom general
electric siemens vous avez dit le
meilleur projet industriel c'est general
electric bon ensuite j'ai cru comprendre
mais par dépêches des agences que vous
disiez bon ça peut se discuter les deux
peuvent se discuter c'est tellement
important au niveau énergétique au
niveau des transports notamment
ferroviaires que là encore j'aurais
besoin d'un éclaircissement je dirais
précis dernière chose donc dans ces
conditions qui s'occupe des véhicules
électriques au gouvernement parce que
vous je sais que vous les défendez bon
je sais que votre collègue montebourg
aussi mais j'aimerai connaitre le pilote
dans l'avion
abbas et les voitures d'école maintenant
eu madame bourzai s'il vous plaît
oui c'est un projet merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre
vous avez récemment indiqué je vous cite
que vous considérez que la mise en
concurrence pure et simple présente des
concessions électrique la du
renouvellement des concessions
électriques présentent des risques pour
l'intérêt général de la gestion de la
ressource en eau de l'équilibré
écologique des vallées et des conditions
de distribution de l'électricité
il faut donc garder un contrôle public
c'est pourquoi vous proposait de créer
des sociétés d'économie mixte à majorité
publique s'inspirant du modèle de la
compagnie nationale du rhône
par ailleurs le dans le programme
national de réforme présenté le 23 avril
par le premier ministre et les précisé
qu'un renouvellement par mise en
concurrence des concessions
d'exploitation des installations
hydroélectriques serait privilégiée
enfin dans cette maison une proposition
de loi a été présenté par certains
sénateur roland courteau et moi-même
entre autres qui propose de prolonger
les concessions de ses installations
hydroélectriques ce qui permettrait de
réaliser les investissements importants
et vous avez parlé de la nécessité de
développer les emplois j'y adhère
totalement je vous signale d'ailleurs
que riveraines de la dordogne pas loin
du lot truyère il y à deux milliards
d'investissements possibles sur les
sources et rivières
et par ailleurs la récente discussion à
bruxelles sur les conditions de marchés
publics permettrait de prolonger ces
concessions alors ma question est
entre ces trois solutions ne pensez-vous
pas que plutôt qu'une seule qui tarde
depuis déjà plusieurs années il
conviendrait d'examiner la solution qui
serait la mieux adaptée pour chacune des
vallées afin de réaliser à la fois les
missions d'intérêt général que doivent
respecter ces installations est
également les investissements qui sont
indispensables à l'économie de l'eau
territoire
merci madame m'a fait revoir monsieur
ronan dantec excuses - rhône oui madame
la ministre vous vous avez une parole
forte et très clair et je crois que nous
sommes nombreux à la soutenir sur deux
points qui de dire l'enjeu c'est bien
les dynamiques économiques et créations
d'emplois qui vont allier à l'ensemble
des transition écologique et énergétique
et que les territoires vont avoir un
rôle absolument central à jouer pour
réussir cette transition et on ne peut
évidemment que partager votre propos
cependant avec notre expérience aussi
des actions nous avons pu mener sur nos
différents territoires on voit bien que
tout cela n'est possible que si on a des
modèles économiques qui fonctionne et
notamment appartement on parle
d'économie de retour sur investissement
crédible et pour la transition
énergétique c'est absolument centrale
mais aussi pour l'ensemble des
investissements nécessaires au
développement
économique or pour cela il faut de
l'argent il faut évidemment mobiliser
l'argent privé est effectivement plus
que temps qu'on ait cette conférence
bancaire qui est un élément clé du débat
national sur la transition énergétique
mais il nous faut aussi un certain
nombre de flux financiers qui renforce
les capacités financières de l'action
publique de l'état ou des collectivités
finalement ces flux financiers possibles
qui sont aujourd'hui sur la table on les
connaît assez bien il y a par exemple
tout ce qui est lié à la taxe carbone
qui aident l'anah aujourd'hui sur la
réhabilitation
on a les certificats d'économie
d'énergie qui sont aussi à une forme de
flux financiers et on sait que dans les
professions de la caisse des dépôts il
joue un rôle assez important sur la part
de réhabilitation on à l'écotaxe pour ce
qui est de l'investissement
transport et on ne voit pas
effectivement très bien aujourd'hui le
lien entre le fait de renforcer ces flux
financiers qui ne sont pas une fiscalité
punitive qui sont mises au service du
développement économique et le discours
volontariste que vous tenez que nous
partageons sur effectivement les
dynamiques de création d'emplois et
d'activités et donc ma question est là
dessus c'est à dire comment vous voyez
l'articulation entre le renforcement de
ces flux financiers d'argent public pour
mobiliser derrière l'argent privé et
faciliter la transition
merci monsieur lannoy
merci monsieur le président merci madame
la ministre nous aurons la possibilité
la semaine prochaine des ministres des
changes avec vous parce qu'il y aura un
débat dans huit jours sur le thème
climat et énergie et donc devront la
possibilité d'en savoir un peu plus et
aux intentions j'ai pris note de ce que
vous avez dit à l'instant et je
souhaiterais en fait consacré mon
intervention à quelques questions qui se
rapportent au volet de l'énergie
transition énergétique
il faut que les choses soient claires et
que le gouvernement affiche la couleur
qu'est ce qu'ils souhaitent qu'est ce
qu'il veut faire aujourd'hui on ne le
sait pas je veux savoir notamment pour
le nucléaire
quelles sont les intentions du
gouvernement monsieur le premier
ministre a exprimé
dimanche soir d'une façon très claire en
rappelant la place
du nucléaire en france il faudrait
savoir dans l'optique du texte que vous
êtes en train de préparer
si vous allez confirmer la place qu'il
doit avoir et dans cette optique je
voudrais savoir quelles sont vos
intentions par rapport à fessenheim il
ya eu un certain nombre de déclarations
qui ont été faits des engagements qui
ont été annoncées est ce que vous
estimez notamment qu'il est possible
comme l'avait dit votre prédécesseur
de fermer si bien de fermer pas
d'arrêter de fermer la centrale
nucléaire de fessenheim
d'ici à fin
deuxièmement concernant le mix
énergétique
quelle est la place qu'il faut trouver
pour compenser le nucléaire que vous ne
ferez plus est ce que comme nos voisins
allemands vous envisagez de renforcer la
place que le charbon occupe aujourd'hui
vous avez parlé d'un exemple qui doit
être affichée par l'europe la france
doit fichiers cet exemple je le dis
comme je le pense
l'allemagne est d'ailleurs il y avait un
quotidien que je ne lis pas tous les
jours mais qui est à l'image de la
pensée des communistes qui dénoncé hier
ce qui se passe en allemagne où la
l'extinction du nucléaire renforce sa
place du charbon un charbon poussiéreux
particulièrement polluants est-ce que
vous avez des ressources qui viennent
compenser la part que nucléaire n'aura
pas d'autant que le renouvelable a
certainement beaucoup de mérite mais
néanmoins un grave défaut c'est qu'il
est intermittent et que faut-il faire
pour équilibrer l'offre et la demande
est ce que d'autre part vous envisagé
que le conseil européen affiche une
volonté d'avoir une politique européenne
de l'énergie et si cette ambition était
affichée comment arrivez vous à
concilier
les situations observées ici et là qui
sont aujourd'hui parfaitement
contradictoire pour ce qui concerne
l'énergie et le président je vais parler
moins longtemps que mes prédécesseurs
assurez vous
concernant sur l'économie vous avez on
ne prête qu'aux riches mais se faire
s'ils résident dans la vie vous avez
reparlé tout à l'heure et c'est un
discours que vous tenez régulièrement de
l'économie circulaire
s'agissant d'électricité je m'interroge
sur les effets de cette économie
circulaire est ce que ça veut dire que
des régions seraient conduites à
construire un système énergétique qui
leur soit propre
est-ce que la conséquence tout cela
n'est pas la mise à mal de la
péréquation tarifaire qui est le socle
de notre système pas seulement
économique mais sociale français enfin
et pour satisfaire
l'exigence du président qui souhaitait
que fussent aussi court que possible je
voudrais vous demander quels sont enfin
quelle est votre position
sur le dossier des gaz de schiste est ce
que vous estimez
que le gouvernement ne devrait pas
respecter la loi du 13 juillet 2011
c'est à dire autorisé la recherche et
l'expérimentation
à vous m'avez surprise monsieur alain
fouché
madame la ministre simplement une
question sur la prévention des risques
que vous avez évoquées et j'ai lu dans
la presse il ya quelques jours et c'est
un dossier qui attire mon attention qui
a choqué beaucoup de gens c'est
notamment un article du monde qui
expliquait que le 2 mai à rotterdam
greenpeace avaient tenté d'empêcher la
livraison de pétrole
qui étaient acheminés par un tank air
russes en provenance de l'arctique est
en fait du pétrole qui étaient livrés à
rotterdam pour la société total
or le président de total quelques mois
avant avait indiqué dans un entretien sa
volonté de ne pas exploiter le pétrole
dans cette région
évoquant le risque de désastre une marée
noire ferait trop de dégâts pour l'image
de la compagnie avait tilapia mais un
pas pour l'accompagner pour le climat et
pour l'ensemble de l'environnement la
question est est simple parce que j'ai
le sentiment que total
encourage le forage dans cette partie de
l'article se sait très bien que pouvait
pas donner la solution mais qu'est ce
que vous pouvez faire
les avis de total avec les autres
gouvernements au niveau de l'europe
voilà ma question parce que c'est un
risque effectivement important pour
l'avenir
si
peut-être faire une exception pour le
président rome qui je sais pas pour
quelle raison il est aussi pressé mais
donc on va faire on va mettre deux fois
le développement durable suivre monsieur
rome mais le développement durable est
une priorité qui rejoint aux
préoccupations de l'économie c'est le
président dans la mesure où madame la
ministre a justement rappelé le lien
étroit qui existe entre les deux
rappelant que la transition énergétique
à laquelle je crois surtout c'est bon
nous espérons tous qu'elle soit la plus
rapide possible et conditionné très
largement par une autre ambition
économique bien plus large qui traite de
la création sur notre territoire d'une
grande infrastructure du numérique qui
permettra d'irriguer avec les objets
connectés bien entendu les perspectives
ambitieuses que madame la ministre a
rappelé que ce soit sur les bâtiments
sur la recherche d'économies d'énergie
sur en fait la création d'une économie
nouvelle qui est en gestation et que le
numérique autorisera ou n'autorisera pas
selon la capacité que nous aurons à
déployer ses réseaux du 21e siècle alors
madame la ministre vous avez également
fait part de votre ambition élargissant
le débat au devenir de notre planète ce
qui est fort légitime car notre ambition
aussi c'est de laisser aux générations
futures si possible un environnement
dans le meilleur état possible pour ce
faire la france sera sous le regard de
tous les projecteurs lors de paris
climat 2015 et il me souviens d'avoir
soulevé auprès du ministre des affaires
étrangères il n'y a pas longtemps dans
cette même salle que l'exemplarité que
l'on exigeait de l'ensemble des nations
du monde devait être aussi illustré par
l'état nation france notamment par la
réalisation de très grands projets qui
répondent très largement à vos
préoccupations et qui pour l illustré de
la plus belle des manières à savoir un
grand projet structurant pour tout le
monde la france et qui touche également
le nord de l'europe à savoir le canal
seine nord europe qui comme vous le
savez est un grand dossier qui pourrait
illustrer la volonté de l'état nation
accompagné d'ailleurs par des décisions
européennes récentes pour que cette
grande infrastructure donne quelque
sorte la marque et la volonté de notre
pays pour faire face à tous ces enjeux
et notamment les enjeux climatiques
pour ce faire madame louise où le savez
il faudra que l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales à côté de
l'état de l'europe soient mobilisés sur
le sujet c'est pour cela que j'ai la
prétention de penser que la clause de
compétence générale serait bien utile
sur ces grands projets qui doivent
obtenir les financements des régions
concernées mais également des
départements
qui en la matière ont affiché leur
volonté
j'ai noté également à madame la ministre
que vous avez invoqué la simplification
sur les lois et règlements
environnementaux
un président de conseil général
que vous indiquez que
entre le moment où l'on décide de
réaliser une déviation routière
lorsqu'on l'imaginent et le moment où
l'on donne le premier coup de pioche il
s'écoule dix ans alors oui je partage
avec vous ce souci que vous avez
témoignés de simplifier certes il faut
protéger l'environnement il faut pas que
l'environnement deviennent l'ennemi de
l'économie pour satisfaire ainsi le
président raúl quelle sera ma conclusion
monsieur le président
monsieur rêver
oui monsieur très bien madame la
ministre vous avez évoqué madame la mise
la question des ogm la question des
pesticides est derrière cela de
l'agrochimie en général en
notant une certaine prise de conscience
du monde du monde agricole la prise de
conscience certes des concevra des
consommateurs elle est énorme mais elle
est encore relative selon nous du monde
agricole on l'a vu dans le cadre des
débats sur les ogm il y a peu de temps
ou dans le cadre du deuxième ronde on a
on a voté comme il le fallait pour
interdire les ogm sur notre territoire
mais le match n'est pas terminé on le
sait aujourd'hui aujourd'hui la
procédure d'autorisation des ogm en
discussion n'est pas satisfaisante et je
crois savoir mme la ministre que vous
même et monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture
souhaité un renforcement de l'évaluation
des risques environnementaux à la niveau
de l'aide de l'autorisation européenne
des conséquences socio-économiques
également des ogm ainsi que des
obligations claires en matière de
coexistence entre les cultures ogm et
non ogm ce qui était extrêmement
difficile donc je crois que le 12 juin
vous participez à la réunion des du
conseil des ministres de l'environnement
et simplement pour vous dire que nous
attendons beaucoup beaucoup de vos
positionnements pour faire infléchir les
positions européennes merci merci
madame la ministre je pense qu'il vaut
mieux qu'on arrête là un peu
il y en a encore autant derrière
monsieur bourquin sur les rivières de
franche comté en effet j'ai là le le
document avec les propositions pour
sauver les rivières ça c'est un problème
extrêmement sensible la question de la
protection des rivières donc j'ai je
suis en train de travailler pour définir
la nouvelle politique de l'eau du
ministère
je voulais vous dire que l'état doit
remplir ses responsabilités donc je suis
en train de regarder peau est ce que je
peux arrêter immédiatement le traitement
des agrumes sur le bord de rivière ça
c'est évident que c'était le déversement
directe de produits chimiques
contaminants dans les rivières est
inadmissible donc il faut regarder quel
est l'impact sur les entreprises sur la
filière bois et pourquoi ils utilisent
encore ces produits
très nocif pour les milieux aquatiques
et par quoi ils peuvent le remplacer oui
c'est l'illustration de ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure sont leur donne un délai
va pas couler les entreprises mais à mon
avis ça fait quand même longtemps
qu'elle aurait dû adopter des méthodes
quand même plus protectrices de
l'environnement je suis convaincu qu'il
existe des produits donc je vais saisir
le nf donc on puisse accompagner les des
forestiers et faire évoluer les méthodes
donc ces gens nous ferons très
rapidement si si vous le souhaitez
d'ailleurs venir alors à l'entretien
avec le nf vous serez le bienvenu comme
ça nous regarderons avec les techniciens
de leurs élèves comment ils peuvent même
venir sur place pour faire évoluer les
pratiques dans ce domaine sur les
lisiers qui sont directement déversée
vers la rivière enfin il faut mettre
partout des unités de méthanisation
inacceptable de faire des épandages de
lisier sur le bord de rivière
j'en sais quelque chose tout ça fait dix
ans qu'on a interdit ça dans la région
que je préside et pendant dix ans et on
a obligé les bandes enherbées le long
des rives de toutes les rivières donc il
faut vraiment que la région s'implique
et des financements qui existent pour ça
pour que le long des rivières comme
autour des nappes d'eau au col des lieux
de captage il y ait des bandes enherbées
qui font filtration naturelle en plus on
est on sait parfaitement maintenant avec
avec l'inra quelles sont les plantes que
l'on utilise pour faire les filtration
naturelle et les bords de rivières
doivent impérativement être plantés en
herbe et en plantes filtrantes et de ne
plus accepter effectivement le
déversement direct dans les lisiers le
round up ya déjà c'est effectivement
c'est pas acceptable là aussi est
normalement il ya des interdictions qui
sont possibles d'utilisation du roundup
là aussi au bord des rivières ou autour
des délais des lieux de captage et
d'ailleurs j'ai l'intention le lancer le
jour de la journée mondiale de la
biodiversité
donc la semaine prochaine
l'opération zéro pesticide en commençant
dans tous les espaces communaux tous les
espaces verts communaux les écoles les
écoles comment est-ce qu'on peut
accepter qu'il ya encore des pesticides
la loi en plus ça a été votée c'est
applicable en 2020 il faut anticiper en
faut anticiper 2020 à quoi ça à quoi ça
ressemble puisque certaines communes ont
réussi à se lancer est ce que vous voyez
bien dans la région il ya plein de
communes qui en maintenant des communes
zéro pesticide c'est formidable et avec
des méthodes maintenant que l'on que
l'on maîtrise complètement donc tous les
espaces verts communaux paramètre zéro
pesticides dans l'agriculture du jour au
lendemain c'est évident mais tout le
train qui a été fait aussi par le
ministre de l'agriculture par rapport
aux à la protection des abeilles quelque
chose la france est importatrice de miel
c'est quand même extravagant donc ça à
cause de l'utilisation des pesticides et
des produits phytosanitaires au moment
où il ya les floraisons arrêtons les
produits de pesticides là où il ya des
élevages d'abeilles et est du coup en
plus il ya une reconquête de la qualité
des de l'ensemencement des productions
végétales c'est un les agriculteurs se
rendre compte qu'en maîtrisant davantage
les produits phytosanitaires ils se
rendent service à eux mêmes dans le
rendement des sols est dans le nom d'
épuisement des sols donc voyez c'est
aussi des cercles vertueux
monsieur louis
alors anticiper plutôt que subir ben oui
bien sûr je ne vous dirai pas le
contraire vous me posez une question sur
l'écotaxe on va attendre les conclusions
je peux rien en dire plus j'ai déjà été
auditionné par l'assemblée j'ai été
auditionné par le sénat donc il ya là
les conclusions du rapport de
l'assemblée j'ai même pas le temps de
l'an d'en prendre connaissance et de la
liberté de la commission et c'est très
bien que le travail existe c'est quand
on me dit à polémique ya polémique c'est
très bien chacun travaille dit ce qu'il
a dit en toute liberté j'ai aussi ma
liberté de parole j'ai été auditionné
dans une vision très grande qualité par
la commission des enquêtes du sénat sur
le i ce i
donc
voilà c'est va attendre les conclusions
des rapports on va regarder on va
essayer d'être le plus intelligente
possible
haut et le plus rapide possible parce
qu'effectivement on attend les
financements jeu bien placé pour le
savoir je signe et le volet mobilité du
contrat de plan état région donc je vois
effectivement les besoins que l'on a et
l'idée effectivement c'est de trouver
des financements
general electric siemens dont on va
prêter des projets pas donner
d'interview donc on va prêter des propos
sur general electric moi j'ai rencontré
ce matin les les patrons de ces masques
alors demandé qui sont venus me voir ce
que je constate quand même dans dans le
fait que l'état français dit on veut
quand même regarder de près ce qui se
passe sur des secteurs stratégiques pour
nous pour la france c'est que les offres
s'améliore comme déjà un progrès
donc voyez donc regardons et on va
prendre encore quelques semaines
l'émergence d'un modèle européen c'est
intéressant aussi parce que les centres
de décision reste en europe donc c'est
aussi intéressant les stratégies
industrielles il faut les regarder le
bilan en termes de création d'emplois et
de et surtout de stratégie industrielle
pour les années qui viennent est aussi
tout à fait crucial donc on va regarder
les choses et ensuite voir ce qui se
passe alors qu'ils s'occupent des
véhicules électriques
c'est comme beaucoup de choses dans le
domaine des industries vertes il ya à la
fois le
le ministère de l'industrie a le
ministère de l'écologie et du
développement durable et de l'énergie
dont j'ai la charge de transports
propres
donc il par exemple déploiement des
bornes
q tu es dans le cadre du projet de loi
sur la transition énergétique de la
mobilité propre et notamment de
l'électromobilité
bernadette bourzai donc sur les
concessions hydroélectriques
alors en effet fait un sujet très
important puisque l'énergie
hydroélectrique et finalement l'énergie
la plus propre qui soit
il est la moins coûteuse et en plus avec
un stockage d'énergie donc c'est une
chance pour la france d'avoir ces
équipements
donc vous vous évoqué la possibilité de
prolonger les concessions c'est vrai que
ce serait la meilleure solution pourquoi
ce serait la meilleure solution parce
que les compagnies pourraient
immédiatement investir sur des projets
industriels qu'elles ont et sur
lesquelles elles attendent d'être
sécurisée sur le futur maintenant il
faut que ça soit autorisée par là par la
commission
donc je me rends lundi bhl à la
commission européenne
sur ce sujet là comme sur d'autres et
pour apporter le dossier et pour plaider
en effet cette possibilité là ce qui
n'empêcherait pas pour le futur quand
même d'imaginer au delà du prolongement
des concessions pourraient quand même
conforme aux règles d'imaginer un
système comme la compagnie nationale du
rhône c'est une société d'économie c'est
un bon modèle
avec éventuellement voilà une adaptation
chose mais dans l'immédiat je rejoins
tout à fait votre point de vue le
meilleur des choses ce serait quand même
la prolongation des concessions ce que
ça sécurise ça stabilise et ça permet
les investissements immédiatement
monsieur roland dantec donc les
territoires ont un rôle central
oui c'est évident vous avez 70 % 2
des actions sur l'efficacité énergétique
sur la transition écologique sont tous
là sont à dimension infranational vous
voyez des impulsions international ya
des impulsions nationale mais le concret
des décisions il se fait sur les
territoires et sur les entrées dans les
entreprises qui sont sur les territoires
donc vous m'interrogez sur le
renforcement des flux financiers
ça va être l'un des sujets importants du
projet de loi parce qu'il va falloir à
ce moment-là que j'ai clarifié donc j'y
travaille beaucoup que j'ai clarifié les
flux financiers dans un contexte qui
n'est pas évident mais je suis convaincu
que si l'on démontre que la transition
énergétique ça rapporte j'entends dire
ça coûte ça coûte ça coûte ça coûte
certes mais ça rapporte des allemands
ils ont mis vannes 2 milliards d'euros
sur la table dans le cadre de leur
banque verte pour faire les travaux
d'isolation énergétique des bâtiments la
performance énergétique des bâtiments et
ça à générer de l'emploi est un des
éléments de la croissance allemande je
suis convaincu que c'est la transition
énergétique et c'est l'investissement
dans la filière bâtiment de façon
extrêmement rapide et extrêmement
performante que vous avez des problèmes
énergétiques
ils ont fait énormément sur la lutte
contre le gaspillage énergétique
nous on a une énergie pléthorique on en
a produit l'énergie au dessus de ce dont
on avait besoin et on observe que du
coup grâce à ce confort énergétique
on a beaucoup plus gaspille on a fait
beaucoup moins attention dans les
constructions à l'isolation énergétique
des bâtiments donc il faut
impérativement rattraper ce retard et
puis faire en sorte surtout grâce à
cette action a donné aux gens qui
habitent ces bâtiments de payer moins de
charges de chauffage et d'électricité
c'est tellement évident quand on voit la
différence des factures entre les
différents pays européens il ya un
problème quand même les français en trop
gaspiller d'énergie dans des passoires
énergétiques et les normes d'isolation
n'ont pas été très contraignante donc
mon souhait d'ailleurs c'est dans le
projet de loi c'est que tous les
bâtiments qui ne sont pas construits
tous soient désormais à énergie passive
à énergie positive
il y en a bien qui le sont pourquoi pas
tous et donc plus on mettra une
dynamique comme ça en disant voilà
maintenant c'est comme ça les tous les
bâtiments que dans le permis de
construire est pas encore déposé vous
ferez des bâtiments à énergie positive
mais les entreprises elles vont être
sécurisés ils vont être stabilisé elles
vont investir l on se dira si tu si
voilà maintenant on peut investir dans
la bonne isolation et dans une autre
façon de construire parce qu'on y est
obligé si on dit ban on va vous avez dix
ans ou vraiment sur certaines conditions
les entreprises sont pas sécurisés elles
peuvent pas investir elles peuvent pas
faire de gains de productivité
si les normes sont floues voyez donc
c'est ça ce sera important de de
débattre au moment du projet loi sur les
dynamiques économiques qu'on enclenche
en étant très au clair sur sur les
différents textes et règlements
monsieur le noir
donc quelles sont les intentions du
gouvernement sur le nucléaire écoutez le
président la république s'était exprimé
donc moi c'est le pot c'est le cadre de
départs sur lequel je travaille est en
prêt en passant les choses contre éclair
au niveau du projet de loi c'est un
sujet difficile vous le savez il ya des
beaucoup d'enjeu et la france de toute
façon et doit être fier de son de son
modèle énergétique
maintenant il faut aussi préparer le
futur préparer l'avenir
et toute entreprise doit aussi évoluer
par rapport à une vision qu'on peut
avoir notre modèle énergétique et est
évident que dans notre modèle
énergétique faut faire monter en
puissance et les économies d'énergie et
les énergies renouvelables et investir
sur les technologies
du stockage de l'énergie la vraie
révolution c'est quand on aura trouvé le
stockage de l'énergie est le pays qui va
trouver le stockage de l'énergie je peux
vous dire qu'il a plus de souci à se
faire pour les dons qu'il faut vous
voyez par exemple que je pense à
l'europe de l'énergie je pense à des
protocoles communs de recherche déjà
entre nos grands groupes français pour
attribuer les les plateformes éoliennes
en mer je les ai réunis pour la première
fois ils étaient tous edf gdf areva
alstom les concurrents ils étaient tous
là je dire vous venez là vous avez été
concurrents sur des projets et vous
devez absolument investir conjointement
sur un ou deux projets du futur pour
qu'on voie les entreprises françaises
dont beaucoup de pme beaucoup de
sous-traitants beaucoup d'entreprises
comme dcns qui est une magnifique
entreprise qui investit sur les
hydroliennes par exemple jamais essayé
essayé ensemble de monter un projet
commun ou des groupes concurrents vont
mettre ensemble leurs laboratoires de
recherche pour trouver quelque chose de
nouveau et donc conquérir ensuite les
marchés mondiaux même chose au niveau
européen et c'est vrai que
l'investissement dans les réseaux
intelligents
dans le rapprochement de l'énergie des
citoyens dans le stockage de l'énergie
il faut vraiment accéléré les choses
pour que dans ce domaine là on continue
à progresser sa déjà énormément
progressé quand on écoute les
scientifiques en cinq ans il ya déjà eu
énormément de progrès dans les
technologies des énergies renouvelables
sur le conseil européen oui je viens de
répondre je pense en effet qu'il faut il
faut une politique européenne de l'herbe
pas tous pas imiter les modèles des uns
des autres on a toute façon pas le même
modèle pour ceux qui refusent de
l'énergie nucléaire ce qui ont une
tradition et des savoir faire dans le
nucléaire entre mais on a quand même
tous un objectif commun c'est de remplir
comme nos obligations sur la lutte
contre l'effet de serre et là c'est nous
qui sommes regardés par le reste du
monde entier on a imposé au pays du sud
au plus haut pays plus pauvres nos modes
de développement industriel à partir des
énergies fossiles garder le drame qui
s'est passé ce matin en turquie ces
épouvantails et 200 morts dans une dans
une explosion d'une mine de charbon
plusieurs centaines de 2,2 d'ouvriers ce
qu'on a connu nous au 19e siècle c'est
épouvantable
donc oui la coopération aussi
énergétique est quelque chose de très
important quand on voit le chantage au
gaz par rapport à l'ukraine c'était
pouvant l'énergie est une source de vie
c'est pas une source de guerre une
source de mort l'énergie c'est la source
de vie sans énergie a pas de planète il
n'y a pas d'espèces n'y a pas de
biodiversité
donc c'est ainsi il faut garder ça à
l'esprit pour que l'énergie reste
toujours une source de vie et ce soit
toujours une solution et pas et pas un
outil de rapport de force un outil de
guerre ou un outil de destruction ou
d'accident
sur les gaz de schiste bon alors vous
connaissez la position du gouvernement
un tant que bon les technologies
n'auront pas évolué sur ce sujet qu'on
aura toujours à faire la fracturation
hydraulique
on ne fera pas de fracturation
hydraulique sur le territoire français
le mans il ya une grande résistance des
riverains
après peut-être si si les technologies
évoluent on regardera mais pour
l'instant dans l'état actuel des choses
il n'y aura pas de
d'exploitation
pas de recherche en grandeur nature en
laboratoire je ne sais pas si de trop ce
qui se passe mais qu'est
monsieur foucher donc sur la prévention
des risques
oui vous avez évoqué le problème de la
sécurité des transports et des
hydrocarbures c'est un vrai sujet parce
qu'il ya un problème de transparence et
un problème de contrôle et c'est vrai
que la direction de la prévention des
risques qui est la mère je salue les
directeurs du ministère qui sont tous là
et qui sont d'ailleurs votre disposition
si vous avez des des sujets très
concrets sur sur votre territoire
donc est en train étant qu'avec le
directeur de l'énergie l'ailier
présentez vous n'avez pas de micros
présentez-vous peut-être allez y
messieurs
la politique de l'eau en particulier
voilà donc sur l'épreuve des
hydrocarbures
voilà mon directeur adjoint de cabinet
ihs les deux correspondants qui sont
auprès de vous deux vous attaché
parlementaire continue et parlementaires
voilà donc effectivement faut qu'on
regarde de plus près la réglementation
j'ai demandé aussi revisite travail et
d'accélérer puis qu'on puisse vous
apporter une réponse précise alors
monsieur rome sur le canal
bon j'ai prononcé des financements
donc je n'ai pas d'avis particulier
c'est vrai que quand on parle de tous
les toutes les alternatives à la route
on parle du canal on parle du fret
ferroviaire et c'est vrai que c'est des
sujets majeurs d'aménagement du
territoire maintenant on sait aussi des
ouvrages lourd et cc des financements
mais bon on peut regarder j'ai pas
encore eu le temps vraiment de me
pencher sur ces sujets là sur les
procédures raccourcir et simplifié mais
là c'est évident c'est un peu tabou
c'est quand on dit on va simplifier on
pense tout de suite maintenant on va
abîmer l'environnement non il ya par
exemple des regroupements des recours
c'est souvent dans le système donc il ya
des recours en attend les que les
recours se succèdent les uns aux autres
non on va regrouper par exemple les
recours pour raccourcir les délais et ça
je crois que c'était un vrai problème
c'est vrai que les recours les délais
sont beaucoup plus longs que dans
d'autres pays et ça c'est pas possible
et on se rend compte que en étant plus
court et plus cohérent et plus
structurée et l'environnement est pas
forcément moins défendu et d'ailleurs
vaut mieux qu'une entreprise sache
beaucoup plus tôt si elle peut pas
construire cette absurde s'y attendait
années pour savoir si elle peut
construire ou pas c'est insupportable
donc même si c'est pour ne pas
construire il vaut mieux le savoir de
façon très vite donc c'est même
l'intérêt des entreprises il n'y a pas
d'opposition entre les
environnementalistes et les entreprises
''cela veut c'est le besoin d'avoir des
règles de droit claire rapide et stable
oui les recours de l'obstruction mais
aussi bons les entreprises qui contourne
les interdits voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est
monsieur l'abbé donc oui vous dites que
la prise de conscience du monde agricole
est relative c'est vrai c'est pareil il
ya des contraintes de production il faut
continuer le travail et puis là quand il
ya des interdictions faut les mettre en
prévenant là aussi c'est pareil c'est
quand les règles sont instables ou pas
claires ou pas franches que les
opérateurs économiques que sont les
agriculteurs sont déstabilisés
maintenant il est évident qu'il faut
réduire le volume des produits
phytosanitaires
la france détient comme le record on n'a
pas pourtant une prune production à
l'hectare qui est supérieur à ce qui se
passe ailleurs et même on a épuisé les
sols avec une utilisation abusive des
produits phytosanitaires
même s'il ya eu des progrès je pense
qu'il faut que ces progrès continus et
surtout que la recherche aussi
s'accélère pour trouver des produits de
substitution qui permettent de protéger
les cultures sans polluer l'air et les
nappes phréatiques
il ya aussi toutes les protocoles de
recherche sur les maladies liées à
l'usagé des produits phytosanitaires et
ça aussi falloir faire la transparence
sur
toutes les maladies surtout les cancers
chez les ouvriers agricoles par exemple
qui ont utilisé pendant des années qui
ont téléchargé des épandages et qui en
subissent des atteintes de terribles sur
leur santé
pardon
oui mais c'est souvent les agriculteurs
qui les ouvriers qui font le travail
allez voir dans les vignes verrez c'est
pas les patrons juifs ont les épandages
ce monsieur sido de toute façon l'air
est pollué aussi donc tout le monde et
tout le monde est contaminé mais quand
on regarde à la mutualité sociale
agricole je fais la typologie des
cancers notamment des cancers du
testicule chez les ouvriers agricoles
vous verrez que c'est assez dramatique
c'est assez dramatique
mais je ne voulais pas du tout opposé
les arroser c'est ce qu'ils sont le
petit jean comptage sido vous aurez la
parole tout à l'heure
bien on va prendre une dernière série de
questions
j'ai le plaisir de revoir
c'est une maison accueillante je vois
pas pourquoi je ne serais pas heureux et
épanoui
madame la ministre je j'ai trois
questions une dans le prolongement de
celle de ma collègue madame bourzai pour
savoir si sur le renouvellement des
concessions hydroélectriques
effectivement il y aura une des
dispositions législatives dans la loi de
transition énergétique
certains territoires souhaitant qu'il y
ait plus de concurrence qu'il n'y en
avait auparavant la cour des comptes
d'ailleurs a montré qu'il était
indépendamment de l'obligation
européenne qu'il y avait pour le
territoire national un manque à gagner
lié au fait qui n'est pas forcément
toujours la concurrence
souhaitait donc je souhaiterais
simplement savoir si effectivement nous
aurons l'occasion de pouvoir discuter de
ces appels d'offres pour les années à
venir vallée par vale pour les 150
concessions hydrauliques qui arrive à
échéance avant 2023
ma deuxième question concerne les
grandes infrastructures transports le
premier ministre dans sa dans son
discours de petits générale devant le
parlement a souhaité une europe qui
accompagnent les pays sur de grands
projets ils concernent beaucoup votre
domaine ministériel
matière développement durable et de
transport il y en a un qui a été cité
c'est le canal seine-nord c'est
effectivement un très grand projet un
beau projet qui est une alternative au
transport routier et il y en a un second
qui effectivement le lyon turin ce sont
d'ailleurs les deux seuls projets qui
pourront être aidés par l'union
européenne à travers la ligne du
mécanisme d'interconnexion européen doté
de 15 milliards d'euros et il est doté à
cette hauteur parce que le président la
république française s'est battu dans le
cadre du cadre financier pluriannuel
2014-2020 pour que cette ligne soit la
dot est la plus haute possible et à 15
milliards nous avons l'assurance que si
nous lançons le canal seine-nord et le
lyon turin ferroviaire nous pouvons
notamment est aidée à hauteur de 40 %
sur les travaux et si nous ne lançons
pas ses projets cet argent ira dans
d'autres pays de l'union européenne
alors c'est le brisant la république qui
s'est vraiment battu pour nous soyons à
15 milliards donc je ne reviendrai pas
sur le canal seine nord mais je dis mon
enthousiasme aussi pour ceux sur ce
sujet mais sur le lyon turin nous devons
la france doit répondre à un appel à
projet avant l'automne pour qu'une
partie de ces 15 milliards soient
affectés à ce projet donc est ce que la
france est en capacité de répondre pour
l'automne à l'appel à projets et
indépendamment de cette réponse pour le
mois de septembre prochain est ce que
vous êtes ouverte madame la ministre à
ce que la france puisse discuter avec
bruxelles pour que nous puissions avoir
une ingénierie financière peut-être
nouvelle en prolongeant par exemple des
concessions autoroutières en
contrepartie de l'implication des
concessions autoroutières sur le
financement de ces infrastructures
ferroviaires la dg move est ouverte il
reste à voir le feu vert de la dg
concurrence mais je sais vous y
travaillez troisième question ça sera
dernière c'est toujours en matière à la
limite de
l'industrie et de la protection de
l'environnement le conseil européen du
20 mars dernier
à la demande de de la france exprimée en
conseil compétitivité du 2 mai 2013 a
souligné l'importance que nous puissions
trouver une solution à l'échelle
européenne pour accompagner les énergies
les industries pardon électro intensives
c'est à dire celles qui doivent
consommer beaucoup d'électricité pour
produire c'est tout ce qui pour une
production d'aluminium du silicium des
traitement des minerais des cimenteries
car un demande ont effectivement
une réponse à la france 2 mai 2013 en
conseil compétitivité on s'est rendu
compte que nous nous interdisions
d'alléger la facture énergétique pour
ses grandes entreprises en europe et
qu'elle était soumise à des concurrences
internationale de pays où il y avait des
aides effectivement sur ces grandes
industries électro-intensives et ses
vingt mille emplois dans en france à la
suite de cette décision du conseil du 21
mars la commission par la voix de
monsieur almunia a indiqué des lignes
directrices début avril 2014 en
indiquant qu'un certain nombre de taxes
qui sont sur l'énergie sur les grandes
entreprises électro-intensifs pourrait
être diminuée la discussion est ouverte
je souhaiterais savoir si nous pouvons
espérer d'ici la loi de transition
énergétique qu'il pourrait y avoir
un accord entre les différents ministres
français je crois que il ya une
convergence de vue entre vous même et
monsieur montebourg pour effectivement
accompagné ces ces entreprises et que
nous puissions enfin stabilisé le
paysage dans le cadre de la loi de
transition vous allez porter pour
assurer qu'il y avait vraiment une
concurrence équitable entre les
industries européennes et celles des
pays tiers merci merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur la parole et à
monsieur poniatowski
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre j'ai qu'une seule question à
vous poser dans le domaine de l'énergie
envisagez vous dans votre texte sur la
transition énergétique de mettre à plat
la tcf e et la cspe je m'explique
la tcf la taxe sur la consommation
finale d'électricité
est aujourd'hui tout simplement une
recette pour les collectivités
territoriales pour les départements pour
les régions pour les villes de plus de
2000 habitants et pour heureusement il
reste un petit quart qui au moins là va
vraiment vers l'énergie pour les
syndicats d'électricité qui sont les
seuls à utiliser le produit de cette
taxe pour des travaux dans le domaine
énergétique électrique et trois autres
collectivités considère ça comme une
recette qu'ils peuvent qui l'on va
l'utiliser aussi bien aux dépenses de
fonctionnement que d'investissement dans
n'importe quel domaine à ce jour la
seule chose qui se profile c'est que un
nouveau niveau de collectivité va se
servir et va prendre une part du gâteau
ce sont les métropoles qui en veulent
aussi mais toujours dans le même
objectif pour que ce soit une recette de
fonctionnement ou d'investissement et en
aucun cas une recette ira vers d'énergie
j'en arrive à la csp les deux questions
enfin les deux la science plus est une
contribution qui elle aussi est payé par
uniquement les consommateurs
d'électricité que ce soit le
consommateur particulier où l'entreprise
et on sait très bien à quoi ça sert à
payer
le tarif social à payer l'électricité
dans les dom tom et en corse et 90% de
la cspe sert à payer les énergies
renouvelables
la ministre vous avez
dit non à la hausse du prix de
l'électricité il ya quelques semaines
vous êtes consciente que vous avez dit
non aux énergies renouvelables
parce que l'augmentation de cette taxe
qui était autorisée par le régulateur
c'était uniquement pour permettre à
l'état de rattraper ce qui est dû à
aider f cdf qui aujourd'hui fait l'
avance de ce prix de rachat de
l'électricité pour l'heureux pour le
photovoltaïque et l'éolien
avec ce que vous venez de décider qui
est une bonne décision l'éolien en mer
la csp eux ne va pas augmenter de 20 ou
30%
elle va être multiplié par deux ou trois
plus encore si d'autres sites en mer
sont retenus autrement dit elle va
exploser or quel que soit le ministre de
droite ou de gauche il faudra bien que
l'état autorise ou trouve un système
pour rembourser à et df ce qu'edf avance
pour le mans
donc ma question je reviens du début est
ce que vous allez profiter de votre
texte la transition est ce que vous
allez accepter des propositions des
suggestions car la seule solution c'est
de remettre l'ensemble à plat c'est à
dire qu'une partie de la tacc l'atc la
tcf est payé par consommateur mais aussi
aux énergies renouvelables en tous les
cas il faut trouver une solution car
tous les ministres vous et vos
successeurs vous serez toujours enclin à
dire non à une trop forte hausse du prix
de l'électricité et donc vous allez
augmenter cette dette qui est dû à aider
merci mais san marin
madame la ministre actuellement
évidemment avec les élections
européennes le débat autour
l'environnement est au coeur de tous les
sujets d'actualité
un récent sondage de l'ifop dia du mois
d'avril a montré que 90 % des français
étaient favorables à la transition
énergétique et à toutes les mesures qui
pouvait l'accompagner le problème c'est
que votre ministère et à mr phare dans
l'actualité mais que si les actions
favorables environnement se font
consensus et moyens ne le font pas et
nous l'avons encore vu aujourd'hui à
propos de l'écotaxe alors je pense
contrairement à ce que dit mon collègue
monsieur le noir c'est vous qui avez
bien dit que vous mainteniez la feuille
de route du président concernant la
centrale nucléaire de faire un live et
donc que vous voulez qu'elle soit
enfin quel ce qu'elle cessait son
activité à partir de 2015 c'est-à-dire
dans un temps extrêmement court ma
question est donc la suivante comment le
gouvernement compte il financé à la fois
les travaux qui s'élèvent selon edf a
soumis millions
plus depuis quelques jours un
dédommagement que demanderaient l'edf
donc ça fait double contrat afin double
contrainte financière et d'autre part
même si la fermeture de faire un homme
se réaliser des façades non excusez-moi
se réaliser cette fermeture ne serait
pas suffisante pour faire baisser la
part de nucléaire de 50% de la
production d'électricité d'ici 2025 et
donc je vous la question je vous pose
concerne l'impasse dans laquelle à mes
yeux se trouve la france aujourd'hui
d'un côté il faut tenir une promesse de
baisser la part du nucléaire de 50% et
d'un autre côté faut respecter la
proposition de la commission européenne
s'est fixé un objectif contraignant de
réduction d'au moins 40% des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
d'ici 2030 par rapport à 1990 car le
nucléaire quelles que soient les
avantages ou désavantages un avantage
c'est de ne pas émettre de gaz à effet
de serre donc la question que je pose
est un petit peu double c'est également
quelles énergies renouvelables
pensez vous pouvoir aujourd'hui mettre
en place sachant qu'il y a des
arbitrages à faire notamment au niveau
de la recherche d'énergies renouvelables
que la cour des comptes a mis un rapport
il ya quelques temps critiquant
certaines pistes et certains
financements d'énergies renouvelables
dont entre autres les panneaux
photovoltaïques dont il ya moi savoir
comment vous allez faire vos arbitrage
et surtout quelle énergie vous pensé de
façon rationnelle pour va être mis en
place et pérenne
monsieur sido
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
j'étais ravie de vous entendre je suis
arrivé un petit peu en retard parce que
c'est en train de traiter le problème
des grandes régions les départements qui
vont disparaître et
les cartes sont déjà d'ailleurs affiché
sur les smartphones et moi je vais vous
parler effectivement encore d'énergie
parce que comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même je pense que vous avez
parfaitement raison sans énergie se
passe rien
c'est clair
et je voudrais revenir sur l'engagement
pris par monsieur le président de la
république
d'abaisser en 2025 à 50% la la
production d'électricité d'origine
nucléaire
ma première question c'est est-ce que à
la lumière de l'expérience acquise dans
par monsieur le président la république
que par les divers ministres de
l'environnement et de l'énergie qui
passe assez rapidement d'ailleurs
j'espère que savard était d'ailleurs
dans le ministère est ce que vous
maintenez l'objectif ou est ce que
finalement est ce que vous imaginez que
on peut faire autrement
parce que et il ya quand même un gros
problème et vous l'avez dit je vous
approuve complètement le groupe problème
des énergies renouvelables c'est bel et
bien le stockage tout à fait exact et
d'ailleurs je dois dire qu'avec le
député bat christian bataille
nous avions commis un rapport à l'époque
sur on parlait pas encore pas de la
transition énergétique et précisément
sur ce qui se passait en allemagne on
avait pris l'exemple etc et je vous
signale qu actuellement puisqu'il n'y a
pas de moyens de stockage de vrais
moyens de ce que suffisant tout au moins
l'allemagne nous exporte de
l'électricité encore hester si nous
export de l'électricité à prix négatif
est un vrai problème et d'ailleurs je
dois dire que les allemands sont très
embêtés en tant que président de
l'office parlementaire j'ai été approché
par un des quatre producteurs je crois
que crw eux en me disant qu actuellement
c'est
d'énormes problèmes en allemagne je ne
veux pas polémiquer en disant que
finalement il importe du charbon des
états unis grâce baisse de schiste et
finalement ils nous ils nous mettent du
co2 dans l'air etc je cherche pas à
polémiquer mais financièrement
d'ailleurs pour ces quatre producteurs
allemands c'est catastrophique
à tel point il m'a supplié
de les auditionner en tant qu'office
parlementaires et le président de
l'office les auditionnera avec d'autres
bien entendu pour que ce soit que
que toutes les opinions puissent
s'exprimer mais j'aimerais bien que
officiellement nous puissions au moins
l'office pour que mes collègues tous nos
collègues puissent en profiter puisque
au fond c'est le rôle de l'office à voir
l'exemple allemand parce que
je n'imagine pas que le gouvernement qui
est au courant de ce qui se passe en
allemagne
prennent le risque de dande aller dans
la même direction avec que forcément les
mêmes inconvénients puisque les mêmes
causes produisent les mêmes effets ce
sera même pire d'ailleurs en france
puisque la part du nucléaire en
allemagne était moindre bien moindre que
la part du nucléaire en france donc je
ne veux pas polémiquer sur fessenheim
etc etc sont les vrais problèmes faut
pas oublier que les suisses et les
allemands et pas qu'edf les suisses et
les allemands nous réclamerons également
des
indemnités puisqu'il en possède
respectivement 17 16% ou quelque chose
comme ça voilà madame la ministre c'est
quelque chose je pense une question
grave
ce que j'ai posée je veux pas polémiquer
mais les français ont le droit de savoir
quels sont les objectifs du gouvernement
merci madame evelyne didier
avant dernière merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre d'abord ça
lui je souhaite saluer votre nomination
mais surtout le périmètre de votre
ministère il serait bien que ce
périmètre la ne bouge plus ça me semble
intéressant du point de vue des
synergies qu'on peut créer sur l'évier
avec les différents sujets
je voulais vous alors plusieurs
questions ont déjà été abordés je n'y
reviens pas je reviens sur le code
minier
le code minier vous le savez avait l'un
des objectifs c'était bien sûr de créer
les nouvelles règles pour l'exploitation
aujourd'hui mais il y avait surtout
aussi l'idée de régler dans un chapitre
la question des dégâts minier une fois
pour toute et d'essayer de solder un peu
ce sujet de telle sorte que nous allions
de l'avant en toute confiance vis-à-vis
des populations et je sais que monsieur
tuyau a fait un travail
qui est tout à fait méritoire que nous
avions salué ici
et c'est dommage un petit peu que le
travail qu'il a fait soit en train de
stagner et qu' il peut donner
l'impression que toutes les parties
prenantes qui ont participé avec
beaucoup de détermination et envie à ce
travail soit mathieu a maintenant dans
l'expectative et se demandent ce que ce
kit ce qu'il va advenir d'autant que le
deuxième l'un des autres sujets abordés
monsieur thuau c'était la question
justement de de la sécurisation des
procédures et il avait fait des
propositions en ce sens en disant voilà
il serait bon que lorsque on engage
quelque chose on puisse tout de suite
consulter les instances concernées type
conseil d'état conseil constitutionnel
pour vérifier la validité de la démarche
pour qu'ensuite signé pardonnez moi
il n'y ait plus aucun recours pour
justement freiner toutes les
ce qui est vrai pour les concessions
minières pour être vrai aussi que
d'autres pour d'autres sujets donc il y
avait là un travail intéressant et je
voudrais savoir ce que vous avez
l'intention d'en faire vous n'avez pas
été précis sur le calendrier peut-être
pourriez-vous l'être davantage quand
donc travaillons nous en séance sur ce
sujet un autre ah oui je voulais saluer
mon collègue le noir parenthèse je note
avec beaucoup de satisfaction qu'il lit
l'humanité est vraiment ça me fait très
plaisir
l'écologie vous madame excusez moi vous
avez évoqué dans une une de vos prises
de paroles l'écologie positive et vous
avez dit qu'il valait mieux
récompenser et encourager que punir je
souscris tout à fait à cette vision des
choses et je crois qu'on obtient bien
plus en encourageant les gens doutent
que ce soit par différents moyens qu
effectivement en punissant d'autant que
nous savons bien les uns et les autres
camps en raison des réductions
d'effectifs nos services de police
douane ou autres n'ont plus vraiment les
moyens d'être très présent sur le
terrain pour sanctionner
donc je vraiment je voulais saluer aussi
cette prise de position
nous avons nous sommes en train de
travailler dans le cadre du conseil
national des déchets et dans différentes
instances sur la question de déchets
dans le cadre de l'économie circulaire
et dans le cadre donc du point que vous
avez signalé sur l'énergie je
m'interroge si vous voulez sur
sur le fait qu' il serait peut être bon
de mettre en avant d'autres sujets que
les déchets pour l'économie circulaire
on a un peu tendance à penser vu les
travaux qui sont mis en avant que la
chaque fois qu'on parle d'économie
circulaire on parle de déchets et donc
il serait peut-être bon davantage de
mettre en avant d'autres sujets en tout
cas dont dans les différentes instances
et enfin je voulais aussi saluer votre
fermeté sur les perturbateurs
endocriniens
ça fait du bien d'avoir des gens qui
prennent des positions très précises sur
ces sujets merci michel teston
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je souhaite vous poser deux
questions
premièrement l'interdiction de la
technique de la fracturation hydraulique
pour l'exploration et l'exploitation des
huiles et gaz de schiste me paraît
essentiel vous avez d'ailleurs eu
l'occasion
en 2011
d'exprimer votre position à ce sujet
lors d'une réunion publique tenue en
ardèche et vous avez rappelé tout à
l'heure quelle était la position du
gouvernement
depuis lors le gouvernement a décidé de
réformer le code minier avec l'objectif
notamment de pouvoir
reconnaître les droits d'information et
de participation du public donc ma
question est la même que celle d'eveline
didier est ce que vous pouvez me donner
une indication sur le calendrier
prévisionnel d'examen au parlement de
cette réforme du code minier la seconde
question porte sur les grandes centrales
de production de chaleur qui utilisent
de très grandes quantités de bois qui se
traduisent par des coupes locales
importantes et par l'importation massive
de bois et donc je souhaiterais savoir
comment repenser réguler
l'approvisionnement des grandes
centrales de production de chaleur à 5e
la ressource locale profite aussi à une
consommation l'eau et qu'elle participe
à une exploitation plus raisonnée de la
ressource en bois
sauf qu'elle n'est pas suffisante mais
madame la ministre vous allez faire les
réponses et la conclusion merci
pour le set nous fait cette nouvelle
salve de questions tout à fait
passionnant comme les précédentes alors
monsieur thierry repentin oui sur le
financement du lyon turin
effectivement cette problématique et a
été évoquée de la prologation des
concessions en contrepartie d'aidés
financement de l'infrastructure
ferroviaire c'est une bonne piste
mais il faut encore obtenir l'accord de
la commission mais je crois je crois
savoir qu'elle était assez ouverte
puisque du côté de la direction générale
transport que du côté de la direction
générale concurrence il ya une ouverture
pourquoi il ya l'ouverture parce que les
routes deviennent financer
l'infrastructure ferroviaire on est dans
la logique du transport propre site du
progrès vers le transport prend donc ça
rejoint la question de tout à l'heure
sur cette problématique
comment est-ce qu'on rend compatible cet
allongement souhaitable et les règles
européennes de libre concurrence
voilà ensuite donc l'autre question
c'est le la question du soutien aux
électro intensifs avec le conseil
européen du 20 mars bon je pense que les
des intérêts des grands industriels on
est en été quand même pris en
considération
on a d'ailleurs fait beaucoup avec ce
ministère et le ministère de l'industrie
on a soutenu les la cogénération on a
soutenu les travaux d'effacement qui
bénéficie aux gros consommateurs
d'électricité
on a on travaille à l'amélioration des
relations entre edf et le consortium
exeltium comme vous le savez on
travaille sur les tarifs de transport
pour les modérés on a maintenu des
exemptions de taxes bref on fait
attention à la productivité et la
compétitivité des électro intensifs mais
on leur dit aussi qu'il faut qu'ils
fassent des efforts c'est bien ceux qui
consomment le plus d'énergie qu'ils
doivent faire le plus d'efforts et voyez
plus on leur dira qu'on va s'arranger et
moins ils feront l'investissement hors
leur intérêt c'est de consommer moins
d'énergie leur intérêt aussi mais
comment il faut retourner les mécaniques
et au lieu que les industriels se disent
bas c'est une contrainte et donc on
réfléchit d'abord pour savoir comment
contourne la contrainte on leur dit non
on est d'accord on vous protège dans un
premier temps mais mais dans un second
temps vous allez avoir obligation de
toutes façons d'utiliser les nouvelles
technologies et de consoles 2 de lutte
contre le gaspillage d'énergie de baisse
de consommation d'énergie et vous en
serez les premiers bénéficiaires donc je
pense qu'il faut à la fois être très
ferme sur les objectifs et en même temps
une vigilance à ne pas le déstabiliser
nos filières industrielles par rapport
aux concurrents en faisant attention que
cet argument n'entraîne pas toujours un
report de l'amélioration énergétique
vous voyez donc ça c'est c'est quand
même très important
monsieur poniatowski donc sur les
différentes taxes donc
concernant effectivement vous avez bien
poser la problématique cela dit
précisément le la hausse annoncée du
prix de l'énergie par edf n'est pas
justement celles qui concernent qui
concerne le
la csp eu précisément donc je crois
qu'il faut faire attention a
effectivement la structuration de la
taxe est précisément l'augmentation
n'est pas liée à l'augmentation de la
csp moi je lui en ai assez d'entendre
que les énergies renouvelables coûte
cher
je les dis d'ailleurs à edf jeudi dans
toutes les énergies coûte cher tout même
l'énergie nucléaire si on inclut le
traitement des déchets ça coûte très
très cher et le prive démantèlement des
centrales donc il faut arrêter la
compétition entre énergie et s'agresser
les uns les autres en fonction des deux
voiliers d'élise et des identités
énergétique toutes les énergies coûte
cher donc on a responsabilité de
diminuer le coût de l'énergie et de
diminuer et d'améliorer le mix
énergétique
par ailleurs le sur la csp 75 % mais bon
pas 90% mais bon je pense que c'est
juste une petite erreur matérielle et
puis
il faut maîtriser le coût bien sûr des
énergies renouvelables est d'ailleurs le
coup commence à baisser
et le nouveau nucléaire il sera sans
doute plus cher que le nucléaire
actuelle donc vous voyez c'est pour ça
que c'est très important que dans le
débat sur l'énergie les chiffres soient
mis sur la table donc et des commissions
dans lequel justement sur le vrai prix
de l'énergie c'est pas pour accuser
telle ou telle ressource énergétique
c'est pour que les élus faisaient depuis
ce faire les bons choix puisse assumer
les choix démocratiques de notre modèle
énergétique sans subir les pressions des
uns des autres on à l'énergie nucléaire
n'est pas question de renoncer de renier
ou de mettre en difficulté ou
ou de porter atteinte à la crédibilité
des des générations d'ingénieurs de
techniciens des ouvriers qui ont permis
de faire émerger cette filière mais il
n'y a pas de tabou non plus et l'intérêt
de l'intérêt national c'est qu'on est
les bons chiffres qu'on puisse échanger
sereinement sur ces sujets qu'on soit au
clair des implications de nos choix et
qu'on ne nous voyez qu'on agresse pas
moi je ne serai pas agresser l'énergie
nucléaire mais je ne serai pas agresser
non plus les énergies renouvelables
alors dans les discours que l'on entend
une espèce de 2,2 d'agression réciproque
et alors qu'on a besoin d'un mix
énergétique et je vais même vous dire
une chose c'est l'intérêt de l'énergie
nucléaire de rentrer dans la logique du
mix énergétique
parce qu'après fukushima
les pays qui veulent s'équiper qui
veulent être indépendants l'énergie on
voit pourquoi il se retournait pas en
partie vers l'énergie nucléaire la
condition que ce soit un mix énergétique
et donc si nos grands opérateurs
énergéticiens sans la femme capable de
rentrer dans la nouvelle génération des
centrales plus contrôler à plus
maîtrisable et c est en même temps aussi
des traits à l'offensive sur le mix
énergétique et donc sur les énergies
renouvelables
d'abord ça revalorisera aussi nos
ingénieurs sa diversifiera nos filières
de formation et on sera plus fort sur la
conquête des marchés internationaux
donc il faut vraiment et je souhaite que
le projet de loi puisse permettre ce
débat là c'est un débat serein pour
qu'on ne cache rien qu'on soit vraiment
au clair sur la réalité du coût
énergétique des implications énergétique
et des procès et des et des modèles
démocratiques qui a derrière les choix
énergétiques ce que ça c'est très
important et moi je me réjouis que la
représentation nationale se saisisse
d'un sujet aussi difficile que celui là
mais qui va déterminer l'avenir notre
pays pour un demi siècle ce qu'on va
décider la sava engagés la trajectoire
industrielles énergétiques de mode de
vie de mode d'habitat de mode de se
déplacer c'est tout si l'asse la
civilisation humaine et l'articulation
entre le l'homme et son milieu à la fois
son milieu naturel et son milieu
artificiel qu'on va essayer de définir
ensemble donc c'est un enjeu tu as fais
tout à fait crucial tout à fait
passionnant en même temps
alors ensuite
oui donc je pourrais aussi vous dire oui
effectivement sur la maîtrise du coût du
coût de l'énergie on peut investir aussi
dans la recherche et développement et
des investissements d'avenir on peut
maîtriser les prix par l'intermédiaire
des appels d'offres on peut baisser les
coûts de production aussi et puis avec
le compteur intelligent ça moi j'y crois
beaucoup au compteur intelligent j'ai
hâte de voir tous les français équipés
du compteur intelligent
donc la semaine prochaine d'ailleurs
j'inaugure un démonstration du compteur
intelligent ce qu'ils veulent c'est pas
loin d'ici c'est une grenelle ils ont
remonté à l'intérieur donc ceux qui
veulent venir et vous êtes bienvenus
mais c'est vrai que la montée en
puissance et l'installation du compteur
intelligent pour que les gens
connaissent leur consommation puisse la
maîtrise et puis cela commandé à
distance ce extraordinaire et si on fait
des territoires énergie positive avec
des compteurs intelligents et de la mise
en commun à la fois de la production ou
de la gestion de l'énergie pas pourquoi
dire partout de l'énergie de proximité
mais ap mais mais mais ça commence à
monter en puissance aussi à ce moment là
ont fait progresser à la fois le modèle
énergétique et le modèle démocratique et
la mise en mouvement des territoires
donc c'est de cela dont on peut se se
saisir maintenant à bras le corps à
condition que tout le monde est accès à
l'information à la connaissance aux
filières comment on fait à qui on
s'adresse etc et moi je vais essayer de
simplifier sa de dire à chacun voilà
comme on fait comment ça le reste vous
l'équipe et votre commune en compteurs
intelligents voilà combien ça coûte
voilà qui vous adresser voilà quels sont
les meilleurs rapports qualité prix et
c'est donc l'accès à l'information ça va
être aussi quelque chose de très
important pour la maîtrise du coût de
l'énergie je vais accélérer parce que
sinon j'aurais plus rien à dire lors du
débat parlementaire
madame
masson maret vous avez reposer des
questions sur le nucléaire moi ce que je
vous propose c'est qu'on a à ce stade je
n'ai rien de plus à vous dire que le ce
que vous savez c'est à dire le cadrage
national qui a été donné on va en
débattre au cours du projet de loi donc
je vous répondra ensemble à toutes les
questions que vous avez posé
monsieur sido donc même réponse à leur
demande est assez bref mais là aussi
vous allez poser des questions sur les
50 % 2
la baisse jusqu'à 50% de la part du
nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité sur les objectifs en
termes de nucléaire on en débattra au
niveau du projet de loi tout sera mis
sur la table tout sera transparent et je
pense qu'on arrivera à
identifier des trajectoires énergétique
tout en maintenant le la compétitivité
de la france et son identité énergétique
madame didier
donc sur le
le merci merci pour les perturbateurs
endocriniens
sur le code minier donc je crois pouvoir
vous dire qu'on leur a vendue avant la
fin de l'année
donc les dégâts miniers sont une réelle
préoccupation pour le ministère le
travail de thierry tuot n'est pas perdu
puisque nous sommes en pareil que nous
finalisons actuellement le projet de
réforme l'idée c'est de le finaliser
d'ici l'été et que le parlement s'en
saisisse avant la fin de l'année
voilà madame evelyne didier donc
sur les économie circulaire ne pas
mettre en avant que les déchets à vous
avez parfaitement raison c'est pas que
la question des déchets c'est la
question de la conception du produit
c'est à dire comment on imagine à
l'origine la durée de vie d'un produit
est d'abord comment conçoit le produit à
la fois pour sa durée de vie c'est
d'ailleurs sa consommation de matières
premières énergétiques durant sa vie et
puis on puisque ce qui devient quand le
produit est usé donc effectivement il ya
la part déchets mais surtout il ya la
façon dont le déchets deviennent
matières premières et donc dans le
déchet entièrement recyclée pour devenir
une matière première les tanks et
créateurs de valeur ajoutée et plus
créateur de destruction et de matières
ou de destruction de valeur parce qu'il
y aura un coût d'élimination du déchet
donc c'est en même temps des sujets très
importants parce que c'est ce qui pousse
en avant aussi l'innovation dans les
différents matériaux
monsieur michel teston
donc sur les gaz de schiste donc j'ai
répondu sur le calendrier du code minier
sur les centrales de production de
chaleur avec importations de bois fsc
c'est un sujet très important que vous
soulignez là il faut faire la
traçabilité
et données des certificats là aussi de
bilan carbone parce que quand le bois
vient de jeu on donne 16 ou pour servir
de matière première pour produire de
l'énergie il ya quand même un problème
de bilan carbone donc on aura dans la
loi à
discuter sur ce qu'est un budget carbone
ce qu'est un bilan carbone et comment on
oriente les décisions par rapport au
coût carbone des des filières de
production qui sont mises en place
voilà je voudrais vous remercier un les
uns et les autres de la richesse de ces
questions qui préfigure je crois un
débat difficile c'est saison des sujets
difficiles parce que sensible et très
variée mais je crois qu'on a devant nous
une oeuvre commune voilà pour l'audition
de ségolène royal la ministre de
l'ecologie on reviendra sur cette
question de la transition énergétique et
de la mise en oeuvre de l'éco-taxe avec
nos invités à 19 heures les sénateurs
ronan dantec et jean bizet mais tout de
suite je vous propose de regarder
l'audition de pierre rené lemas ancien
secrétaire général de l'elysée il était
entendu par les sénateurs cet après midi
car il est le candidat choisi par
françois hollande pour succéder à
jean-pierre juillet à la tête de la
caisse des dépôts on regarde tout de
suite son audition et on se retrouve à
19 heures monsieur présidente sur leur
pourtour g